[Music]
[Applause]
uh let's make way for the Hall of Famer
Steve Young and uh let me see do I run
down all these you got three Super Bowl
rings from the Niners Super Bowl MVP
two-time
MVP former ESPN anal anything else did I
leave out anything here Dan you got it
no one at my house cares anyway so don't
worry about it really no
no they don't the football's not
although the girls remember I coached
their flag football this fall and the
girls suddenly let yesterday they're
like what why is he waving his harm when
the punt I'm like it's a fair catch it's
a fair catch you don't know what a fair
catch is you know like no what does that
mean like oh wow so that's that has been
fun that the girls are you know kind of
interested in it do the dads though they
know who you are so they geek out when
they meet
you
uh it it depends you know I mean there's
49 faithful you know we live we live in
the area you know I always said if uh if
I got in trouble I'd uh i' drive to
Modesto immediately they'd protect me so
there's a lot of good people around here
I never thanked you publicly at least I
don't think so when we were on the
sidelines when the Steelers beat the
Cardinals in the Super Bowl and Ben got
the ball for the two-minute drill MH and
I'm going to hand out the trophy and
you're right there next to me and you
were doing playby playay as if you were
quarterbacking the Steelers and it's one
of it's one of the more wonderful
moments I've had in broadcasting
because we I'm we're all thinking like
what's Ben thinking or going to do and
you're you're telling me what he should
do or oh my God that was unbelievable
and then he leads him down for the
touchdown yeah was great and then I
never saw you after that it's but I I it
was wonderful it was but he made it I
thought he should have been MVP I mean
he he to do that with the game on the
line like that after what Kurt Warner
just did I mean that was a very
underrated Super Bowl it felt like super
underrated and uh and the throw of the
corner to win it was like I mean it was
it was a magical little I mean you and I
were standing right there we're like
three feet away yeah and uh and it's to
me it's fun in the NFL if you can be
down on the field uh because that's kind
of it's easy to do it from the booth
because you can you know but but to be
in the guts of it and then and then
react like you know as if you were
playing it because you're you know you
visibility on the field is a little bit
reduced from you know mean I I find
myself now I'll be at one a high school
game or something watching The Stand I'm
like pleas throw it throw it and I can't
believe I I would turn I was like I just
said to myself how that where did you
come from that you would actually be
you'd reduce yourself to being in the
stands yelling a quarterback back to
throw it you've got to be kidding me
after all the years I was talking about
Dak Prescott that when you're the
Cowboys quarterback you get too much
credit too much blame and I don't know
if there's another fan base that has
that much pressure but can you equate
any of that to the 49ers fan base I know
it's not as large as the Cowboys but
yeah well I mean Joe Montana
did a number on me to kind of put some
Target on me right so it's like you know
you there's a fan base that's uh if you
think about the Cowboy fan base the fan
base that is like uh hyper focus is
probably about the size of our fan base
so it's like um yeah you quarterback
when when when when there's an
expectation at quarterback and I don't
not every town has expectations around
everyone like loves the quarterback but
there's certain towns where the
quarterback is everything and only thing
and San Francisco is one of those places
Dallas is one of those places you got
two you know both have two first ballot
Hall of Famers you know they just they
have history you know I mean where a lot
of places don't have history of
quarterback Chicago you know you know
like they they would love a great
quarterback but it's not like they're
used to it right and so that's why
Justin's got such a hill to climb in
some ways in a different way where if
you're you're you're a 49er or a Cowboy
quarterback the the Hill's already in
place you know it's good luck I was
watching Zach Wilson yesterday and uh an
analyst said he goes through his
progressions too quickly
and I'm curious about like what is too
quick and what's not quick enough like
that clock that's in your head of what
you do and I think you've talked about
this before to me that you like looked
there'd be one read and then you just
take it and then you'd
run you had to you have to go through
that uh that mental that clock that's
ticking but you know how there's a pace
to it there's a pace to it Dan and
you're making a very good point I was
always too fast you know I was fast
getting back Bill Walsh to say look you
got to slow your your drop you got to
slow down because you know we time
everything off of back then the West
Coast offense was always about your
footwork decided where you throw the
foot throw the football it's less that
way out of the gun shotgun but your
football decided it so you're so fast
you're ready the team has not the the
play has not prepared for you yet and so
you had to slow down and and I think
what what you're describing for Zach is
a mental slowdown because you're so U
look football the quarterbacking is all
about adrenaline control when everyone
has adrenaline in the game because
everyone's full of you know the 880,000
people screaming is that can you control
your Aden you actually reduce it as
things go crazy as the play goes on you
your adrenaline stays Pat or Goes Down
And if you don't you'll you'll Chase it
with your your brain goes fast right
everything's going fast your visibility
goes down it's all the same stuff every
quarterback fights it and guys that
haven't played very much in the pros
until you can teach yourself that or can
kind of go through it enough that that
that happens you you end up in a space
where you're always racing through it
and uh no and and the play the play
can't you know the play can't be done in
a way that's productive it's like you're
ready to throw it then you go to the
next guy he's not ready to throw up
because he's supposed to be waiting for
the other guy and then you go through
the whole PR then you go then you go to
scramble then you go down and the coach
screams at you what are you doing you're
like well I did exactly what I was told
yeah you did exactly what you were told
too fast and it doesn't work I think
it's a great
Point how do you learn to throw a
receiver open in the NFL when you
normally don't have to do that in
college well Les the game has changed a
lot with the with the with you know the
the safety rules where you can't you
know launch your body as a Defender so
they get there's space a lot more space
that used to be I would say you know in
college every every receiver is open and
in the pros nobody's open so that was I
would say that in college everybody's
still open or even more open and the
pros is they're they're more open than
they've ever been but anticipatory
throwing is what I try to I try to tell
other quarterbacks it's like if you
don't see that coming you'll be too late
so then people say well wait now I'm too
early now I'm too late it's like yeah
that's why there's only five guys in the
world that can be like you know
generational Talent at this because it's
the it's the be able to there's you know
processing has always been the key
elements of NFL quarterback so that's
and that processing has to be timely it
has to be and then and then to deliver
the football that's why you have to be
have a great brain and a great arm and
together you have anticipatory throwing
that's what's fun to watch and I I after
I retired I you know I'd be on the
sidelines with you like you describe you
saw Ben or you watch pton or you watch
Tom and it's that that was the gift that
they all had that everyone else chased
but just they have great brains they
didn't have the they have armor they
didn't have they never put it all
together or they were too fast or
they're too slow and there was just a
you know that's why I love quarterback
and that's why I love the game it's like
a kerto right it's like it's got to be
just perfect it's got the pitch and the
feel and the timing has got to be
perfect and when you see great players
play Dan as you know you stand behind
him in the end zone I used to love to
stand in the goal poost and watch from
behind and you just say oh my that thing
came out and it's just like that nothing
had by the time the ball was out of his
hand nothing had happened and then while
the ball was in the air it all happened
and then bam and there was there's
something really beautiful about it he's
the Hall of Famer Steve Young joining us
Dan Patrick Show would you rather have a
great offensive tackle or a great wide
receiver I mean that's tough but the
your point is that a tackle like Trent
Williams of the
49ers you can see it when he's in the
game when he not it's just it's like a
shutdown Corner would you rather have a
shutdown corner or a great Edge rusher I
think you'd probably say look a shutdown
Corner allows the other 10 guys to do
things that are just unavailable without
it and so a great tackle it's the same
as a shutdown corner you now close down
a side and that allows the other 10 guys
to do so if you if you don't have Hall
of Fame receiver but you have a Hall of
Fame TI
you're you're you're your all pro
receiver now is a Hall of Fame receiver
like it elevates everybody and I think
that's why I think that's the point
you're making I think I agree with that
I mean Trent Williams is probably people
say he's the greatest football player
ever I've heard that been said and I
can't say that that's not true at this
point because he just there's no one
that's ever dominated a position like
that now you know Anthony Munoz you know
there's some great Al Larry Allen out
there Larry Allen but but I mean Trent
is unique he can on the run and the pass
can just completely dominate a game and
that's why um and quarterback you you've
seen it every week the only thing that
stops quarterbacks and get today's game
is pressure because people are open
there are open spaces and and then
quarterbacks can go run for a free yard
so it's like a fun game to play I mean I
look I I've said it to you before I'd
love to play today it' be a lot of fun
to go run around and make it happen but
uh but you can't the only defense that
defending NFL defenses have today is
four guys to for the passer that's
because the game hasn't changed in the
pass rush it's changed in coverage it's
changed in tackling but it has not
changed in pass rushing the you know the
safety protocols have not affected the
pass rush and that's why it's still
that's why it's been leaned into by
defensive uh coordinators and every we
got four guys and they got to bring the
heat because that's our only shot are
the ners set at
quarterback I mean how can you say no at
this point it's unbelievable to me that
the you the the game has always been a
processing game Dan I mean and you've
got an elite processor 23y old Elite
processor and that's you watch it every
weekend but how do you know you have
that I always call It's like Star Wars I
always say it's the force you know when
Obi-Wan Kenobi turns to Luke Skywalkers
you have the force and everyone goes
well what is that because it's
Indescribable it's this thing that we
just talked about the brain and the
ability and the anticip anticipation the
timing and a sense and it's like a g
it's a it's a and that's why I say it's
the force like the kid has the force and
uh and people you know that's why he
wasn't why did you get drafted the last
guy in the draft because the force is
hard to judge you're just not sure and
look I always say that even Brock
doesn't know it until he does it and
then he then you know kind of re it's a
revelation for everybody and that's true
for anyone in the NFL all comes to you
because you know you can say Oh I'm
great I know I can do it you're not
really until you do it then all but I
maintain that he had a harder time he
had to throw people open in college
where some of these other quarterbacks
probably played with you know CJ strad
he didn't have to throw anybody open
Brock pie had to throw people open at
Iowa State so he might have been ready
you make the point that Brock is gonna
have he's not the Prototype the
Prototype is Jaylen Herz CJ Stout who is
just I think is is thatone doesn't
understand when you watch the tape he is
ah head of the game he is an anti
anticipatory thrower like that's when
you know someone's going to get better
and better and better because they have
that gift yeah so those are the Brock
can't throw it as late as as CJ can as
late as Jaylen can because his AR it's
like it's different so he has to do it
in a more even more guish ways I don't
know if that's a word but like he has to
actually be ahead and that's why he's
gotten into trouble in the three losses
where the ball's coming out he had the
ball has to come out and that's one of
his gifts but it has to come out so fast
and early and the anticipation that it's
like it hasn't fully developed where the
other guys can hang for the extra
quarter of second they can watch for a
little bit longer and then they can get
out of the pocket stiff arm a defensive
lineman get out and throw at 60 yards so
Brock's gonna have to do it like it like
if if CJ or or jaylen's going to take
three steps Brock's going to take five
but he's going to be so efficient and
good at it that he's instead of you know
he's going to be five for five when
other guys have to be three for three so
that's just a fact and he's going to
have to do that in the biggest games and
he's going to have to do it coming from
behind the the NFL today Dan every game
it feels like comes down the last couple
possessions of the fourth quarter that
was never the case before it was always
more St stodgy more thick it was like
you couldn't make that big the cudes of
scoring like back and forth it's like
the NBA today you and you've got five
guys in the league or six that you give
the ball in the hands in the last couple
of drives and they will get it done and
uh and Brock needs to constantly work
extra to be one of those guys but I
think he can would you have a harder
time trying to describe to somebody who
had never seen Patrick Mahomes play or
Travis Kelce
play they are subtle it is subtle it's
it's um but both of them have the same
gift of presence in space
like all the chaos and all they have a
they have a sense
of a place in in in in in motion and
Patrick I the first time I saw him play
in Denver on a Monday night it was the
second game I say he was scrambling left
and someone's chasing him you know and
all and then you know usually a new
quarter Young quarterback they're now
they're I don't care how settled you are
and how present you are your mind is
racing right you're scrambling out of
the pocket you're running as hard as you
can you're you're desperate for someone
to be open and all of a sudden he kind
of settles in and flicks it left-handed
kind of you know over a guy's head and
and completion I'm like you have that's
the ultimate that you can be in the most
incredible moments of adrenaline and
it's like no dude I'm right it's peace
bro peace you know and so Travis has the
same sense of spatial relationships you
ever notice where he's kind of in
between a couple of guys and he kind of
just puts his body a certain way and you
throw at that and then and and Patrick
feels that and then and then the other
thing is when he starts to run he you'd
say he was a
lumberer but he he gains so much space
in every every step that it's like he's
lumbering right by you you know and so
there are they're both unique but
Patrick is Pat and what I love about
Patrick Dan is that he recognized that
processing and the play out of the
Huddle is the most valuable thing in the
game and he decided you know instead of
being Superman the most important thing
I can do to be Superman is to do the
basic blocking and tackling of calling
the play dropping back and getting the
ball out of my hand on time and he
started to work at that after the 19
Super Bowl run he said look I can make
all the plays I get that but I'm not
getting over the hump because I'm
missing all those you know nuts and
bolts plays the the the the the basics
and so he went back and played basic
football got the ball out became much
more efficient and what that did was
then allowed him when he did go
to be really Superman and that's what
his game has changed over the last
couple years and that's why he's so
dangerous and to me so almost impossible
to beat because he's gonna beat you out
of the Huddle and he's gonna beat you
out on the perimeter and I uh that
that's the dream that's the Prototype
today that's the dream that's the that's
my game I that's my the whole those full
circle I just want to come back and play
that's all that matters that's all I
want to do D I just want to come back
and play this is my I was the odity in
1990 I was like he's a lefty Scrambler
get him off the field I can't hate those
guys and now today ah you know you're
like welcome come on in could Steve
could you help the Jets right
now yeah the Jets I mean no you had
quarterback oh quarterback yeah no I
could look I game today you saw I will
say this Payton never wanted to leave
the game but his arm went out he would
still probably be trying to play Tom
played as long as he possibly could
because they knew that they were trained
in a more uh sophisticated era that's a
fact and they were taking advantage of
it and abusing the system because they
were trained in a different era and the
people were open Tom once said to me the
flats are always open the middle of the
field is unpatrolled which in the middle
of the field in the day you went in
there with your life on the line yeah he
says and no one can hit me and it said
that's the game that I can dominate in
and so if you were trained at a more
sophisticated day like Aaron Rogers why
is Aaron Rogers trying to get back after
four months because I I was trained in a
more sophisticated era and I'm abusing
the system give me on the field because
it's a it's a and these are the last of
the guys Aaron's probably the last guy
that was trained uh that way and uh and
so everyone else will now be trained in
a new era and it's probably not as as
like anything is your arm strong enough
to help the
Jets yes I can throw a few balls all
right okay don't get me dream Dan don't
get me dreaming man stop your your wife
your wife's gonna get mad at me but
Steve Young says he can help the Jets I
like that as a quarterback make the
headline D bring the drama bring the
drama yep uh and then I then I escape
the pocket once and four hamstrings go
and then where are
we Happy Thanksgiving to the family
always great to talk to you thank you
buddy you're the best that's Hall of
Famer Steve doing